so there's this advice that's been
floating around in the architecture
community and
i've been given this advice and a lot of
people actually follow this advice
and the advice is that it really doesn't
matter whether you get licensed or not
because if you're working for a firm
you're not going to be stamping drawings
and there's not a huge difference in
salary
and in fact there's a lot of architects
a lot of great architects who are not
licensed
and it's a fair argument because
the path to licensure is long and
expensive and once you get licensed you
have to pay thousands of dollars and
yearly fees all of a sudden you have all
this legal responsibility and you get
sued
and here in bc we have what you call the
green sheet
which is like a email newsletter that
calls out and publicly humiliates
architects who've done some professional
misconduct
so
today
i wanna clear the air and answer the
question
is it really worth it to get your
architectural license
so first i want to talk about the
difference between a licensed architect
and a unlicensed designer
and then i want to talk about the pros
and cons of getting licensed and of
course my personal opinion about it
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dammy and i
am a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc
and by the way licensed architect
doesn't that just sound a little bit
better than an intern architect on this
channel we talk about architecture and
design and also some tools and
strategies that can help us have more
meaningful and fulfilling careers in
architecture so what is the difference
between a licensed architect and a
unlicensed designer or an intern
architect
so when i was an intern i used to hate
this word
it's quite demeaning because
society has a pretty strong connotation
for the word intern but legally in north
america if you're not licensed you are
technically an intern
and according to naab's definition
intern refers to
any individual in the process of
satisfying a registration board's
experience requirements
this includes anyone not registered to
practice architecture in a u.s or
canadian jurisdiction graduates from
naab accredited programs architecture
students who acquire experience prior to
graduation and other qualified
individuals identified by a registration
board and this is all because there's a
huge difference between what you learned
in school and the real practice of
architecture
and unless you go through the program
and meet all the requirements you don't
have the right to call yourself an
architect and you don't have the right
to practice i don't know if you guys
know bob borson he writes the blog life
of an architect
he had a pretty interesting piece on
this and he puts it really well he says
not having the right to license really
boils down to
not having the right to be held
accountable for the public
for protecting their health safety and
welfare or in other words the right to
be sued for screwing up like i said i
really used to hate the word intern but
actually after going through the process
myself i
realized that
because there are so many things that we
do that
have to do with the well-being of the
public
and that if you can't be held
responsible for it then you should not
be allowed to call yourself an architect
i'm sorry interns i still support you in
the u.s
the aia supports the use of the term
architectural associate and design
professional instead of intern
but uh legally well it's it really
depends on your jurisdiction and your
state
but uh yeah legally in the eyes of naab
and cacb if you're not licensed you're
still referred to as an intern architect
so i am of two minds on this and
obviously i decided to get license but i
think both arguments are valid so i'm
going to present the case for both based
on my personal experience
and
my personal opinions
so these are the most common reasons
people say getting license is not worth
it people say it costs too much
it's expensive the cost of exams yearly
fees which for me is around a thousand
dollars a year
the fee to join the continuing education
and of course there's a liability and
responsibility and of course the good
old i've been working in the field for
10 years i already know how to be an
architect argument and the biggest
reason for me
um
would be like the liability and
responsibility aspect of it i have
always had like
side hustles when i was an intern
like i did small renovations or like
interior design jobs or drafting jobs on
the side for
friends or small clients
but as a licensed architect technically
you can't do any of that work so you can
only do work that you're kind of signing
off on as a professional
and
you're giving assurance that the
building's going to be built to a
certain standard in terms of like life
safety and accessibility
giving assurance that you've kind of
checked all the necessary building codes
to make sure of time what this means is
that let's say
i want to do a small renault for a
friend right and my friend wants me to
help him like redesign his apartment and
submit permits for
moving around a couple walls
ripping out the ceiling and he's gonna
do the construction himself or get a
couple of his friends to help like i
used to do this all the time draw it up
submit it with my name and with my
contact info
and we get a electrical or like a
mechanical engineer to
submit his letter of assurance and this
is completely legal you can do this as
an unlicensed designer now that i am a
licensed architect i need to take
responsibility to oversee the
construction
now
because my friend is not a reputable
contractor
i don't really want any part in that
and because if anything if anything goes
wrong it could get messy if these small
jobs are a big part of your income then
maybe it's not the best idea for you
another scenario i've seen is i've
actually seen this happen to quite a few
of my friends because there is quite a
big film industry here in vancouver
um so sometimes architects will work as
set designers or art directors
for the film industry
like designing movie sets
but
according to our local jurisdiction the
aibc
this is frowned upon because
once again
you're building things that's gonna last
a couple weeks or a couple months
and you're tearing it down right after
that and that's
that that's in conflict with the
responsibility to oversee construction
and to make good buildings
yeah
i know it's extremely
stringent
every jurisdiction is different so you
should check with yours
but i think yeah this is the main thing
to keep in mind if you are someone who
kind of wants to straddle different
industries and roles that involve
construction
but is not exactly the role of a
licensed architect before we go into my
next argument i want to share a little
message from our sponsor skillshare
now i'm gonna build the case for why you
should get licensed
based on my personal experience other
than the fact that your parents finally
believe that you're not delivering
coffee in the office
you also get knowledge and competence
respect and confidence
and money
so whether you get licensed or not the
internship process and the whole
examination process
is designed to make sure
that you are well equipped to design and
construct safe and
healthy buildings
it's designed to
make sure you have the ability to manage
projects and coordinate with your
consultants and it ensures that you
also understand all the legal
responsibilities of an architect and i
think there is a real difference between
learning through experience and actually
sitting down and studying for it
although learning through experience is
equally important it's very different
when i started working i felt very
overwhelmed with all of the amount of
things that i didn't know
like i didn't even know what a contract
or rfi was but when i started studying
for it i realized
okay there's like all of these things
that i have to know
um like regarding code envelopes and
practice and i can actually start
listing off the things that i don't know
and i can start making steps towards
learning all those things and also
you're learning from primary resources
you're not going to your co-workers who
might have taken the exam like five
years ago
and the information first of all changes
every single year so it could not be
accurate and maybe they don't remember
properly
so yeah that's another important thing
and you're also condensing that learning
time
as opposed to if you were to just rely
on learning through your co-workers or
through your project
you'll kind of have to wait you know
you'll have to wait for the project to
be in a certain stage for you to gain
experience in that but when you're
studying for it you don't really have to
if you're curious about the actual
requirements that you have to get
through to become licensed
i have a video on that
and i'll leave it right here and number
two is respect it is true
the outside world is cruel to interns
and
the world will definitely give you more
credit than when you're an intern
but
more importantly for me
i gained more self-respect for myself
because
after going through the licensure
process
i
might not have had all of the years of
experience but at least
i know what i don't know
and
i know what i have to watch out for
and i know exactly where to go to look
for that information and so with that
knowledge on my side i felt more
confident
and like slowly and slowly i started
feeling less like an imposter
which is good
last but not least money
the source of all happiness
just kidding guys
meaning and enjoyment in your work is
definitely more important than anything
else
but
getting my license has helped me get a
1.4 times increase in my salary this was
the offer from two different firms so i
know that this is not
an anomaly
and i'm not stamping drawings at this
firm but from the point of view of a
firm owner
if you see that someone's a licensed
architect
even if they only have like three or
four years of experience
they know that they've gone through the
process from starting and finishing a
construction project
they know that they've studied and
finished all of the exams
naturally they become more valuable to
the firm i think you can work in
architecture for 10 years and still not
learn all the things that you need to
know to become an architect
because when you're in a firm
it's not profitable for them to put you
on things that you don't know
it's much more efficient for you to
continue doing what you're good at so
the firm doesn't have to spend time
which is money
on teaching you new things
so that is the reason why just because
you have tons of years of experience
you cannot be considered
an architect
so after listening to this what do you
think do you think it's worth getting
your license
let me know in the comments below i'm
really curious to see what you think
thanks for watching
[Music]
you